[Music]
on this Sunday night fears of a wider
War Israeli is told to flee as clashes
escalate at the Lebanese border the US
increases its military presence in the
region intensifying air strikes rip
apart more families in Gaza and Israel's
error at the Egyptian border how the
conflict is causing issues in Canadian
schools it's too hard to understand the
distracted the best way to explain the
crisis to kids Trudeau in trouble what
internal polling reveals about the PM's
popularity refugees feeling forgotten
it's becoming longer than before uh now
it's almost 2 years waiting for the
hearing a new life on hold because of a
bureaucratic
[Music]
backlog global national with bar an
answerer good evening there are new
fears tonight the bloody battle between
Israel and Hamas could swell into a
wider War Israel is pounding Gaza and in
a statement today the military admitted
it also accidentally hit an Egyptian
post near the border with Gaza an
Egyptian Army spokesperson said several
border guards were injured the US is
increasing its military presence in the
area and along Israel's tents northern
border with Lebanon fears of another
front opening with iran-backed Hezbollah
Palestinians stuck in Gaza are scared
and they're running out of food and
water today for the second day in a row
some Aid trucks entered but it's not
nearly enough the UN also reported today
29 staff members have been killed in
Gaza since the conflict began our Jeff
simple starts us off in Jerusalem
tonight with the escalating tensions
Jeff Farah if Hamas thought that
releasing two Israeli American hostages
on Friday would see a reduction in
Israeli air strikes it was wrong the
night sky over Gaza doesn't stay dark
for
long Israeli war planes struck targets
across Gaza overnight as well as a
mosque in the West Bank and two airports
in
Syria we intensified our attacks and
dozens of terrorists were killed said
this Israeli military spokesperson he
repeated Israel's warning for residents
in Gaza to move to the South for their
own safety people in this home had
followed that evacuation order but their
building south of Gaza City was
flattened anyway an Israeli air strike
reportedly killing at least six people
and injuring dozens
more staff at this Gaza Hospital are
caring for the most vulnerable patients
for whom time is running
out
more premature births are occurring due
to the war the obstetrician says she
warns the hospital will run out of fuel
within
hours both the incubators and the
heating require electricity if these
babies don't stay warm they will die
from the cold or they'll die because we
run out of medications for newborns she
says the UN estimates the fuel supply in
all of Gaza will be finished unless than
three days I mean this is a we are
Beyond a humanitarian catastrophe and we
can't even imagine the day after in
Gaza a second Convoy of humanitarian Aid
was allowed to enter Gaza from Egypt
though officials said it did not include
fuel around 14 trucks this time that's
fewer than Saturday and just a fraction
of what the UN says is desperately
needed this is the reality yes it's a
drop in the ocean and I'm puzzled by the
fact that in International Community
doesn't come to term with the fact that
there is a need for an immediate
ceasefire the Israeli government says
there will be no ceasefire until all
hostages in Gaza are freed Israel now
says 212 people are being held there so
we just want them back home this Israeli
school teacher survived the Hamas attack
on her community she says some of her
students are now among the hostages we
just want the hostages back we just want
the hostages back they didn't do
anything
they are
kids she and other Israeli evacuees say
the pro Palestinian protests in Canada
and other countries are hard to stomach
we only defending ourself we don't want
to kill anyone we want to be safe in our
homes they are terrorists in September
11 no one no one stood stood by the
terrorist why now people stood by them
why people are justifying somehow the
the the Hamas I don't understand they
are terrorist organization while Western
societies appear divided Western leaders
are for the most part standing firmly
behind Israel the French President and
the Dutch prime minister are scheduled
to visit Israel this week on the heels
of their British and American
counterparts the Canadian prime
minister's office says Justin Trudeau
has no plans to visit Farah Jeff SLE in
Jerusalem tonight thank you Jeff
Canada's defense minister says the
Canadian Armed Forces has done an
independent review an analysis of
Tuesday's explosion at the Al Ali
Hospital in Gaza in a statement released
late yesterday Bill Blair said the
analysis indicates with a high degree of
confidence that Israel did not strike
the hospital and that the more likely
scenario is that the strike was caused
by an errant rocket fired from Gaza
hundreds of people were killed along
Israel's northern border with Lebanon 14
more Villages have been added to an
expanded evacuation Zone Israeli Defense
Forces say they've hit Hezbollah
infrastructure in response to the
militant group attempting to launch
anti-tank missiles towards Israel
roughly 4,000 people have been forced
from their homes on the Lebanese side
Crystal ganing joins us now from Beirut
and Crystal what do we know about the
Canadians in
Lebanon far there's roughly 14,000
Canadians registered as being here in
Lebanon the Canadian Armed Forces says
it's preparing for the possibility that
it might need to help get those
Canadians out of the country today
Israel's prime minister spent the day on
the northern border with troops and he
was talking to them about Hezbollah
saying he can't guarantee them if
Hezbollah will enter the war but he
tried to boost their morale saying and I
quote we will [__] it with a force it
cannot even
imagine the Israeli government press
office released these images of another
troop Tour by the Israeli Prime Minister
this time he wasn't talking about Hamas
but Hezbollah the Lebanese
militia if Hezbollah decides to enter
the war he says it will miss the second
Lebanon war it will make the mistake of
its life since October 7th the two sides
have been attacking one another
sporadically but to deadly effect both
sides are moving citizens further away
from the hostilities and while neither
is taking things to the next level
they're also not letting the situation
diffuse
either he's deputy secretary General
said on Saturday we tell all of those
who contact us to stop the aggression so
that its repercussions and the
possibilities for its expansion will
stop however as long as the aggressor
continues no one can guarantee anything
a barrel of gunpowder is how Iran's
foreign minister describe the situation
in the region both Hezbollah and Hamas
are a part of what Iran calls its access
of resistance as for Citizens on both
sides of the borders they are preparing
to leave and trying to find somewhere
safe to go and wondering if they will
have a home to go back to far Crystal
Gand sing in Beirut thank you Crystal
police in several Canadian cities say
there has been a noticeable spike in
hate crimes in recent weeks weeks
against both Jewish and Muslim
communities Heather yks West has that
story those that knew her say ctha wall
made the world a better place the
well-known member of Detroit's Jewish
Community was found stabbed to death
outside her home Saturday night so Sam
was a board member of the Jewish
community relations Council American
Jewish committee here in Detroit she was
also president of the downtown synagogue
the death comes just a week after the
killing of a 6-year-old boy in Illinois
oi police say the Palestinian American
child was the victim of a vicious
anti-muslim attack it's a spillover of
violence from the Middle East that
Canadian communities are seeing as well
in Toronto there have been 14 hate
crimes reported in the last couple of
weeks 12 have been related to
anti-Semitism two have been related to
anti-muslim anti-islamic events the
center for Israel and Jewish Affairs say
reports of anti-Semitic incidents are up
across the country leaving community
members feeling vulnerable and exposed
we have to be vigilant uh that we don't
import conflict from abroad um uh it is
difficult for all of the stakeholders
communities um to try and make sense of
things to try and find a way forward
Canada's Muslim Community has also seen
an increase in horrific hate crimes in
recent years the man accused of using
his vehicle to run down and murder four
members of a Muslim family in in London
Ontario 2 years ago is currently
standing trial we need to address head
on the problem of anti-palestinian
racism that is quite widespread in
Canadian institutions both media
politics education and elsewhere
Canadians grieving for those lost abroad
now worry increasingly for their safety
at home too Heather urx West Global News
Calgary internal government polling
obtained by global news shows that in
most provinces Canadian see the federal
government as being on the wrong track
our chief political correspondent David
Aken has been going over the polling for
us and David it seems the results show
the government is struggling to win
approval from Canadians well far our
prime minister Justin Trudeau and his
closest advisers rely heavily on data on
numbers that can tell a story Trudeau's
pmo in fact is the first in history to
ask the privy Council Office the PCO to
run a comprehensive weekly polling
program to track its own performance and
keep on top of the issues Canadians
think are
important Global News used access to
information laws to get those internal
polls the most recent are from January
to June but they tell a clear story
Canadians were giving the government a
failing grade the polls show that more
Canadians said the government was on the
wrong track every week for 6 months and
that gap between wrong and right was
widening the pmo got the message and in
July the Prime Minister shuffled his
cabinet putting one of his Rising Stars
Nova scotia's Shan Fraser as the point
person on housing that was an issue
those internal polls had also flagged as
one that needed urgent attention but the
Prime Minister kept his environment
minister in place Montreal MP Steven
Gilbo and the PM's advisers could point
to their internal polls again for that
decision first Quebec voters
consistently rated climate change and
the environment as the most important
issue of the day even as Canadians in
Ontario the west and Atlantic Canada
were saying that the cost of housing and
inflation was the number one issue
second Quebec was the only region where
more voters consistently said the
Trudeau government was on the right
track rather than the wrong track if the
Trudeau government loses support in
Quebec well that is the ball game in the
next election and that's one of the big
takeaways from this series of internal
polling the Trudeau government has
little choice but to gear its priorities
to the priorities of quebeckers even if
those priorities might be at odds with
the rest of the country far David Aken
in Ottawa thank you for your coverage
David tens of thousands of refugees
stuck in limbo coming up how Canada's
immigration backlog is forcing Asylum
Seekers to wait years for a
decision and also coming up the St
Lawrence Seaway shut down why hundreds
walked off the
job
Canada's auditor general says the
federal government needs to improve how
it manages immigration programs her new
report finds that refugees are stuck in
Immigration processing delays stretching
back almost three years as shagufa Danes
tells us it's created a permanent
residency backlog that's left one Afghan
woman in Ottawa feeling
forgotten Amina K is not an artist but
penting is a way for her to C it helped
me to you know to um to distress jaar
earned her master's degree in the US and
was planning to return home when the
Afghan government collapsed 2 years ago
with her student visa expiring she
crossed into Canada as a refugee
beginning another challenging journey I
was carrying this fear all the time with
me that uh what happens if I'm not
accepted the Catholic Center Cent for
immigrants helped refugees like havari
resettle in Canada and navigate the many
obstacles to starting over now it's
becoming longer than before uh now it's
almost 2
years waiting for the hearing I don't
understand why honestly in a skaing
report Federal auditor general Karen
Hogan found there were 999,000 Refugee
applications still wai to be processed
in a department with higher workload and
fewer staff we found that most delays
and backlogs were caused by the
Department's own processes immigration
Minister Mark Miller says the government
is taking action we are opening a
permanent residence online portal to
refugees which will help accelerate that
but obviously the proof will be in the
pudding H's Refugee claim was approved
but she is now stuck in another backlog
waiting to become a permanent resident
without it she cannot visit her sick
mother in Afghanistan with my status I'm
not able to do anything for them I feel
myself like as a um hopeless person U to
be honest she has found some hope Kar
has an apartment and a full-time job
with the Catholic Center for immigrants
I really wanted to give back and then
help those refugees in Need by helping
others she is helping herself get
through this difficult time as she
weighs through a bureaucratic backlog
hopeful for a new life in Canada shugu
Fones Global News
arwa Argentina votes ahead a close
presidential race in a time of economic
crisis hundreds of workers have walked
off the job at the St Lawrence
Seaway negotiations between unifor and
the employer went up to the midnight
deadline with the two sides remaining
apart on
wages I understand that a strike is
disruptive but but but that's the way to
do it that's the mostly only power that
the worker got we know that about $17
billion doll in trade moves through the
St Lawrence seway each year so A
disruption to a critical artery like
this is bound to have significant
impacts on Industrial Supply chains both
upstream and downstream so we can
imagine a strike like this having knock
on impacts throughout the economies of
both Canada and the US the shipping
artery includes 15 locks and it runs
between Montreal and Lake
Erie in Argentina the polls have just
closed for the South American country's
presidential election and the most
important issue for voters was its dire
economy inflation is well above 100 100%
but the campaign was also dominated by a
controversial libertarian candidate he's
called climate change a socialist lie he
promised to abolish Argentina's currency
and he believes selling human organs
should be legal Redmond Shannon
reports he may look like an aging 70s
Rockstar but Javier M's politics are
very much of the modern
era the front runner in Argentina's
presidential election is chopping down
political norms and conventions very
much in the style of Donald Trump and
Brazil's J businaro
his slogan is Long Live Freedom damn it
the Brash TV pundit and libertarian
Economist wants to abolish Argentina's
currency and its Central
Bank he also wants to ditch some
government departments the climate
skeptic has proposed restricting
abortion rights too Malay is striking a
cord with voters who feel they have
nothing to lose what was once one of the
world's leading economies is now mired
in its latest economic crisis inflation
is rampant at
140% and two in five live below the
poverty line Malay has suggested making
it legal for people to sell their
organs this Malay supporter says
Argentina needs change
but this woman says malle's policies are
simply
cruel Mal's two main opponents are from
the traditional center right and Center
left in Argentina the current economy
Minister Sergio Massa and conservative
Patrica bullrich a winning candidate
likely needs 45% to claim victory after
this first round otherwise there will be
a runoff next month in another
similarity with Donald Trump Malay says
if he doesn't win win he could allege
voter fraud something he claims cost him
5% in August's primaries although he
never provided evidence Redmond Shannon
Global News
London talking to Children about war
next strategies to help build
empathy the violent images and news
coming out of the Middle East are having
an impact on many people and places and
that includes schoolyards and classrooms
as Mika reports experts say it's
important to break it down in a way
children can relate
to you kidnap survivors lines are
clearly drawn with competing points of
view do not believe the Israeli
mouthpiece and their spokes people
what's abundantly clear is the anger
that exists the hate down with Zionism
down with Zionism it's impossible for
any of us kids included to ignore last
week a predominantly Jewish school in
Toronto reported instances of
anti-Semitism and islamophobia with one
parent saying her kid was told I can't
sit beside you because you're Muslim and
Muslims kill Jews kids no longer friends
because of a complicated geopolitical
conflict that began long before they
were born hard to understand
why why is this war and we don't
understand it it doesn't make sense we
don't understand terrorism it's just too
hard to explain those words and that
concept but we can understand and
explain the way we feel so how do we
talk to our kids for one it's important
not to incite more violence with actions
or words rather teach them compassion
Through The Eyes of the Innocents caught
in the crossfire like this 13-year-old
boy trying to survive in Gaza it's not
the kid's fault that this will happen
it's no one's fault it's not fair that
this is happening it shouldn't be
happening it's helpful to prioritize
Humanity by telling these individual
stories to help children appreciate that
they have similar wishes and hopes just
like other people across the
world they don't have to understand the
politics or see the evidence of the
atrocities being committed they just
have to learn that there are no winners
in conflicts like these Mike trle Global
News
Toronto and that's global national for
this Sunday night I'm far AER and on
behalf of our whole crew here I want to
thank you so much for spending part of
your evening with us tonight's your
Canada is elmir Island nun until next
time take care of yourselves and take
care of each other good
[Music]
night
n